anxiety at work like I still when I get
a script or it's my first day on the job
like I don't sleep the night before I'm
always terrified I don't want to [__] up
I'm terrified I'm not gonna I'm gonna
disappoint everybody they're gonna be
like oh I can't believe I had her you
know
every time still get that
every time and then once you're complete
a scene or find it and you're like okay
you're then you're good
yeah I have this thing where I feel like
I'm gonna be found out like always we
all have that yeah this is the job where
they're like oh she's not that talented
she's just pretty it's fine
you know and every time I am genuinely
shocked surprised happy that somebody
takes me seriously and that somebody
goes
you have something to offer of course I
do and I should earn that and believe
that and like come in with that right
this is why I think men are a lot more
successful at times than women is I like
I get
like I feel like I don't deserve it or
something it's
well that's silly to think that you
don't deserve it and you know what's
funny is I'm saying that because I I do
the same thing
why are you nervous why are you not
trusting yourself and sometimes you
could be so great in a scene so
committed so intense so everything you
knew you could do deep down and it works
but then the next time you forget about
how good you were and you're back to
square one all insecure unsure of
yourself and I I'm like I have to be
insane yeah yeah you know it's crazy
it's crazy and it's crazy making because
I think and and this is where
I do think this like small amount of
Prozac has helped
um is that it shuts that down a little
bit for me
even though that's more associated with
anxiety or whatever but the self-doubt
part I think comes from like a
depression and or like a value thing you
know and and it shuts that down a little
and it makes me able to be a little bit
more daring a little bit more
um
let me see what happens if I do this
thing that I want to do
yeah you know I I really appreciate you
talking about that because I never
I've never had any guests or anyone talk
about like PMs and depression with that
and taking Prozac and like the stigma
that's attached to all these
antidepressants or anti-anxiety but
people's brains are different the
genetics are different sometimes you're
inherently you have these things